Thank you, Mayu.
Sorry.
I didn't think I would get so small.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Happy anniversary.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous!
You would think that like...
If I have an anniversary...
My first anniversary that I'm celebrating...
Three years later...
That I would be more prepared.
You would think that...
I would be more prepared.
But I'm...
Not.
Oh, gosh.
Can and Mintai...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's stop this now.
This slander.
Just hang out?
I have some...
I have a few things.
Um...
Some...
Uh...
Plans, I suppose.
Anyway, welcome everybody to my not-birthday.
Oh!
Okay.
To my not-birthday.
I'll never have a birthday.
I'll have a death day.
Thank you for...
Thank you guys for all the gifted memberships.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Kept us waiting.
Huh?
Truly.
Um...
Yeah.
Any plans for anime-NYC.
I can neither confirm, nor deny anything.
A dragon.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh...
Pyro bug.
Thank you for the 50 giftign.
Thank you!
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the Hakasuba flux!
Thank you!
Happy anniversary...
Oh my god, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my god...
Happy anniversary, thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
I just started!
I just started the stream!
Um...
On this day...
Four years ago?
On this day, four years ago...
I streamed for the first time ever in my afterlife.
Oh my god, thank you!
Kept this waiting for a while...
Katsu, thank you for the 50...
Thank you guys for all the gifts and memberships!
And all the super chats!
I'm getting a little overwhelmed...
But um...
Yeah...
I never...
I had never streamed before...
And...
Why is...
YouTube broken?
Wait, hold on...
I think YouTube...
Has been broken for a bit...
I think it's been broken...
But...
It says I have so many viewers, but I don't think that's the case.
I don't think so...
I'm seeing 20...
Yeah, that's too many, I think...
That's...
I don't think that's normal...
I think that's actually broken.
I think it's broken.
I don't think it's that many.
I think it's being weird.
I think after the Cloud Strife, it's broken.
I think so.
It is broken!
It's... Anyway.
Welcome.
I'm watching on three devices.
Stop.
Oh my gosh.
If anything, it's too little.
No!
I don't want it to be that much.
It's too much.
No, I feel much more comfortable if it's just a normal... If it's just a normal map.
Oh gosh.
I have 50 tabs open.
Well, for everybody who's real... If you're here... Sorry, my voice is a little hoarse.
Thank you for the peek!
Thank you so much.
My bot farm.
Yeah.
Oh no, my account's gonna get banned.
I'm real.
I'm real!
Yeah, my voice is a little hoarse because I was... I went to an event this weekend, you know.
Will you ever unprivate your first ever bot?
I don't think... I don't know.
You guys even want to hear that?
I... What's the word?
I will be watching it.
Oh gosh.
I'm nervous though.
I don't want today's stream to be super duper long.
Yay, Corko!
Thank you for the 50!
Totally not a bot.
Unprivate your intro video.
You're telling me I'm not real?
Oh gosh.
I'm really nervous though.
So today, I have... I have a few things to...
I don't want to say announce.
Maybe... maybe to... to announce briefly.
To briefly... to exclaim?
I have things I want to...
Speak?
To scream?
Just a bot.
Announce to announce.
Yeah.
Basically, I will say something and be like...
Tease?
Tease is a good way, right?
I think tease is a... is a...
Tease.
I have things I would like to tickle you a little bit with.
But I... I don't have so much.
But after we watch some of my old stuff...
After we watch some of my old stuff, then I will...
I will...
I will announce that and then...
I might do like a little bit of VR and...
Stuff like that.
But it is... it's so crazy that I'm...
It's my first ever...
Anniversary celebration, so...
Yes.
And then I also have a little bit of a giveaway.
Which I'm not sure how to do yet because...
I literally received this stuff today.
And I'm like...
I don't know how to distribute it yet.
But...
I was given some stuff to give out today.
Maybe I'll figure out a way.
Maybe we can brainstorm together.
As a group, you know.
Fulton it.
Well, it's not physical.
So I can kind of just, you know...
My ball!
Yeah.
We'll figure out something.
Some...
Oh, gosh.
I'm so...
I'm so nervous.
But...
Shall we just...
Start?
Rip off the band-aid?
Again, I feel so unprepared.
I feel so unprepared.
Yeah, go ahead.
I'm so nervous.
I...
Let's see.
I'm going to my videos.
Actually, let's start with my first ever uploaded video, right?
My intro video, which...
Who...
Who asked me to un-private this?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I'm so nervous.
I don't remember...
I kind of remember my intro video because, you know...
I took some...
I took a good amount of time, like...
Editing it and everything like that.
But...
For my first ever stream...
I don't remember that at all.
Like, I remember...
Well, I say at all.
I remember having, like, nothing.
And it being...
It being kind of dumb.
So...
Okay, hold on.
We're going to do this.
And we're going to make me small.
I want to see the cringe.
Oh!
And also, to continue the cringe...
I have a heart rate monitor.
Here, I'll put it down here.
For...
When things are too strong.
How does a ghost use a heart rate monitor?
Don't ask.
Wait.
Is this...
Hold on.
It's a little...
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, god!
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
It's like an EMF reader.
True!
True, true, true.
True, true, true, true.
Oh, my gosh.
Fuck...
Fasundo?
I hope I said that right.
Thank you for the birthday gift.
Thank you.
Happy anniversary, boss.
Thank you, Oh, my gosh.
I don't know what to say.
I have a letter disease.
Okay!
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I love 나왔어, and your heart.
I experienced a lot of pain over there.
My fortune -telling team won't let me through this time.
Let's all watch together.
I'm gonna put my glasses on though.
Like, you know how...
when there's like a roast, people wear glasses so they don't seem like affected?
That's me right now.
Hennyson, thank you!
Is that Hennyson by Xander?
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm ready for cringing.
Sorry about that.
If you heard that, that was OBS just stuttering for a second.
If you heard the OBS stuttering, I'm so sorry.
I don't know, everything is wrong with either me or YouTube or what.
Okay, are we ready to cring- Oh god.
Are we ready to cringe?
Oh god, okay, okay.
Happy Anniversary, thank you!
So this was uploaded four years ago.
July 18th...
July 18th, 2020.
I liked my own video!
You know what?
Self-love, maybe.
I just saw it!
Oh my gosh, July 18th, 2020.
So long ago.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh gosh, you can see my- It's like telling me my next dream is me.
Okay, okay, oh my gosh.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Three, two, one.
Wait, it's too loud.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, hello, my name is Mint Phantom.
My name is Mint Phantom.
Welcome to my channel!
Why is there nothing, no audio?
So my name is Mint, I'm forever 19.
I'm forever 19!
I'm an eternal maid.
So just to introduce myself since I'm new.
Some things that I really like are idols, anime, horror, bubble tea, and most of all, most of all, most of all, most of all, maids and cute girls.
I sound like I need to clear my throat.
Ramen and almond rice, but I really dislike masago and anything spicy.
Nobody cares!
I just can't have it.
I'll die.
I'll die again.
So when I'm not haunting a maid cafe, I really just like to watch idols and anime.
An idol group I love in particular is Nijinokunki.
Yeah, Nijikan!
And I go watch their music videos.
I got a little freaky there.
I love Zangaran Saga and Ring Hero.
Wow, I still like those.
And I basically also have seen basically every episode of Detective Conan.
Mintante Conan!
When you're a ghost, you just have so much free time on your hands.
So I've never really been good at video games or speaking.
And so I thought...
Why are her hands like that?
So I thought becoming a VTuber would help motivate me to get better about it.
That's how I improved, everybody!
And talk to more people because I'm very shy.
Like, think Boo from Mario.
He's so shy.
Censor.
That's me.
Don't look at me.
Don't get me.
I want to play a lot of horror games even though they really, really do scare me.
I'm going to do my best to...
Don't say limp-wristed.
I think maybe if everyone's there working with me, it won't be so scary.
I'll try to be brave.
Yeah.
I think my Japanese is okay.
It's okay.
I think I've regressed a little bit.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Mintante.
My Japanese is not that good yet.
But I want to talk to everyone.
So I'm going to study every day.
Study every day.
Let's talk every day.
Pre-MGS.
So there's things that I want to do and I hope that I can get better with practice.
Please be patient with me.
I'm a ghost.
I'm haunting.
My full-time haunting.
It may take me some time to get used to everything but I look forward to talking with all of you.
And I really want to collab with all the other really cute girls.
I do hope that I can learn a lot though.
And also collaborate with other VTubers.
And I hope you're looking forward to my content.
So thank you so much for watching.
And I hope you'll follow me on Twitter.
And subscribe to my channel for future videos.
And yeah.
Thanks for watching.
I don't really know what else to say.
Have I changed?
Okay, bye.
Whoops.
Have I changed at all?
I seem so shy.
I seem so baby.
I'm just like...
My mic changed for sure.
Definitely.
I just peaked at 1.16 when the bikini showed up.
She used to be so cute.
What the?
I'm still kind of cute.
It sounds more relaxed now than she was back then.
I remember recording this in my closet.
I used to have to stream in my closet.
And I do remember recording this.
And I...
I don't even...
I was so nervous, you know.
I was like...
I never made a video like this before.
So I was...
I didn't even know.
So...
Mata loves me.
Mata!
Before Zanzibar.
Is Mata here?
Hello.
Oh!
Roachmomrid!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Oh, man.
That wasn't so bad.
There were some things I remembered.
The...
Don't look at me.
Look at me.
It was like kind of an inside joke between me and some friends.
So...
So that's why I remember it.
Because I would just be like...
Basically, I would say like...
For my waifu and stuff, I would be like...
Don't look at her.
Because she's my waifu.
But then I'd be like...
Look at her.
Because, you know...
She's...
I want everybody to look at how cute my waifu is.
So I'd say...
Don't look at me.
Look at me.
Don't look at her.
Look at her.
So that's...
That's where that kind of came from.
And then...
Let's see.
This part is so awkward.
I think I was truly just too lazy to edit in any sound effects at that moment.
But this is all the same stuff.
Things that...
Why did I make a list of my likes but I didn't make a list of my dislikes?
I only said it.
Koine!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
Pusha!
And...
But I still like idols.
I still like anime, I still like horror, I still like bubble tea, I still like moe things!
I think everything is the same.
Oh, I left a space here!
I left a space here for Metal Gear!
Maybe.
It's a good one actually, I'll write that down.
But yeah, there's a room here for Metal Gear.
It was foretold!
Hold on, I can even add it!
I can add it right now!
I'm rewriting history!
Metal Gear...
What's this font that I used?
This was on my laptop, I don't think I have it anymore.
Oh no!
It was on my laptop.
I don't think I have it anymore.
Wait.
Maybe?
No way.
It's...
Close enough.
It looks pretty close!
I wonder if it's... wait.
It looks a little bolded.
Galaxy, thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Wait.
Maru?
Normal.
It looks the same to me.
Anyway.
I've rewritten history.
Let's see what else was here.
Have you guys seen...
Here, I'll show you the...
I'll show you what the...
The quick...
Here, let's watch it in slow-mo.
So we can get that...
I also uploaded this at 720p.
If you're like, oh, she looks a little fuzzy.
Yeah.
Because I'm an idiot.
It's at 720p.
So this is Nijin no Konkisudo.
They're an idol group and I still like them very much.
But let's go to that .25 playback.
Oh my god.
I even missed it.
So...
Yeah, you should go watch their music video.
I'm sorry.
It doesn't sound so good.
You should go watch their music video.
Mm-hmm.
Mm -hmm.
Oh my goodness.
Let's see.
What else did I talk about in here?
Zombieland Saga and ReZero.
I still very much like both of those.
And then I talk about Conan too.
But I have not watched.
I'm behind.
I'm behind on Metante Conan.
I'm not...
I'm way behind, actually.
I'm way, way, way behind.
What is this?
Oh, so I thought counter.
I'm very shy.
I think that's still the same.
I want to play horror games.
But I don't know.
I'm scared.
But I'm scared.
And then I talk in Japanese.
Nihongo.
Um...
Mint brain goes brrrrr.
Um, thank you for the vibe gifted.
You've gotten better with your shyness.
You think so?
Oh, thanks so much for watching.
And then it goes shoooooo.
Oh my gosh.
The next part is the one I'm really scared about.
Shady, thank you for the Hakusopa.
Can't wait to see next video.
It's the next year's anniversary where you react to your react to your intro video.
No, this is the part that I... we're going into un... into territory that I do not remember.
This is my... it'll be my first ever... first ever stream.
We're not gonna watch all of it, but um... but uh... we will watch something.
Hold on, I have to scroll all the way to the end.
There we go.
Um, the first.
Oh my gosh.
I don't remember anything that happens in this.
Okay, hold on.
Ta-Dah!
The first- The first ever!
NEVER Ever Ever Next life ever lives.
Ever, ever.
And that's the date.
Oh,
I can't read the comments because they're like...
It says you can't for... Oh, thank goodness.
I did not like my own livestream.
But you can't see it on private videos, which is kind of sad.
I don't know how this is so...
But also, I think maybe I should set the mood a little bit.
Give me one second.
I think I hear my computer.
Wait, where is this?
Here we go.
One second.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
What is wrong with me?
Why did I size it like this?
Are you kidding me?
Past Minto, what's wrong with you?
Okay.
And then...
There we go.
I still have all my old graphics.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
I still have all of them.
Here, we'll get rid of the disc too.
I keep basically everything.
I keep almost everything because I am a hoarder and a freak.
Maybe.
I still have almost, I think, all of my old, like, thumbnails even.
Like this one.
I tried to do an 8-hour endurance stream.
This is the thumbnail, right?
But it kept... Look at that.
Thank you for 3,000.
That's what it says.
But YouTube did not like the booba part, so I had to, like...
I had to censor it.
It's called 8-hour thumbnail FFS.
Because I was getting so frustrated at the fact that it was not allowing me to use the thumbnail.
Let's see.
Here...
We have 1,000 subs, Minto.
Thank you everybody for...
Why do I look like that?
It looks like I wasn't ready for the photo.
It looks like I'm not ready for the photo.
Let's see.
I have so much stuff.
Look!
Even that you saw in the other thing, my likes and my dislikes, here it is.
It's the graphic.
You blinked.
I blinked.
I still keep everything.
I'm not even kidding.
I have every... I think... I have so much here.
I have everything here.
No way!
I know!
Add Metal Gear to the list.
I should.
I have, like, almost all of my old schedules.
Let's see what I did.
Here.
I'm just gonna put on some BGM.
Since I'm talking a little bit before we get into the...
Into the stream.
Into my first ever...
I almost said Haishin.
Let's see.
What did I do on January 4th through January 10th?
Done.
I played Slither.io.
And I played Among Us.
And I finished Ace Attorney.
And then I did a game collab.
Look at this schedule.
I only would stream a couple days a week because I did...
I mentioned it.
I had a full-time haunting.
So...
Let's see.
What did I do?
November 23rd.
Done.
I played Doom.
I played Doom for the first time.
And I played Pacify with Maria.
And Phasmophobia.
And Among Us with Chat.
Nothing is Chase.
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
I wonder when you finish Doom.
Yeah.
And I went through...
Let's see.
Um...
Uh...
I had like special things too.
Like...
Like 3k subs.
I did an endurance stream.
And I did...
I don't remember playing Ao Oni.
I don't remember ever playing that game.
Did I actually play that?
Then I played Touhou Mountain of Faith.
I did Jackbox with the FanDome.
Aka you guys, the Wisps.
Getting Over It.
Karaoke.
Free Chat.
Marshmallow.
Time to play again.
Touhou Mansion.
So...
Yeah.
Love Touhou.
So yeah.
I...
Oh my gosh.
You know what's even crazier is I have like the files.
I have the PSDs of these schedules as well.
So I could just totally redo them if I ever wanted to.
Isn't that so wild?
And then this was before.
This was the schedule when I was reviewing how I look now.
So cute.
I played Sonic.
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Why don't I have Monday on here?
If I already have break and break...
Maybe I didn't... Maybe I took Mondays off every time, because full-time haunting plus, you know, I don't want to... I don't want to work on... I don't want to go do Monday work and then also stream Monday.
Garfield rep.
Garfield rep, truly.
Six boxes look nice too?
You think so?
I thought it was a little difficult to read.
Because... here, hold on.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you're so probably right.
Right?
Yeah.
If it was seven boxes, that wouldn't make much sense.
Yeah, so just having the six box, but it's hard to read, right?
Because you have to go...
Like you have to zigzag through it.
It's hard to read.
Doing it in the lines.
I don't know.
I always struggled with my schedule.
You played Sonic on Mario Day?
Wait, when did I play it?
When did I play it?
No way.
Oh my gosh, I'm such a hater.
Wait.
8, 9, 10.
No!
I played it on the 11th.
I played it March 11th.
8, 9, 10, 11.
Barely safe.
You got a horrible case of the Mondays.
It's true.
Saved.
I'm a tired.
Mario Day in Asia.
No, I streamed it the day after.
It would have been Mario Day...
It would have been the day after Mario Day in Asia.
So close to being a certified Chris Pratt hater.
You're right.
Alrighty, guys.
Are we ready for this?
I'm not.
Why did I put... Why did I lift my...
Oh, gosh.
I think I'm just gonna... Oh, gosh.
Thank you.
You're a soup.
Okay.
Sorry if you can hear so much noise.
I think the fan is going a little bit crazy.
But...
And also, my cat, she keeps jumping on my desk and ruining my cables.
Rip the Band-Aid off.
Okay.
I still use this PGM.
I didn't realize I used it for my starting screen as well.
I didn't...
I made this though, right?
I just was like, meow.
I made my starting students screen.
Please wait a little.
Louder?
No.
Okay.
I'm gonna skip.
Oh, gosh.
Cherry.
Gary.
Thanks for the 50.
I look like I don't know where I am.
Why am I not saying anything?
Mint, say something.
Hello?
I can hear...
Do you guys hear that?
Do you guys hear the...
Sage, right?
It's my laptop fan.
Oh, my God.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Oh, girly.
Yes, we can.
The screen is moving so fast.
Hello?
Hi.
Toaster mic.
Welcome back.
Oh, my God.
It sounds so awful.
Hi.
Hello.
It sounds so different.
There are so many people.
Oh, my God.
It sounds okay.
It sounds... Am I good?
It sounds like I'm on Xbox.
I'm alive.
I'm here.
I'm not alive.
What are you talking about?
Minto.
I'm gonna skip.
First donation.
Oh, no.
Is my mic bad?
Oh.
I'm shaking.
Oh, no.
Is my mic...
You guys, is my mic bad?
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Oh, my gosh.
There are so many people.
I think...
I don't remember how many people were watching at the time.
Do you still have this mic?
I don't.
Because you know what this mic was?
It actually was a headset.
And I...
Oh.
That...
I...
I was gonna...
I was going to buy the same headset that I had for this stream right now to kind of recreate the moment.
But because of everything that happened, because of all the plane stuff, I wasn't able to.
So...
You sound like you're in a COD lobby.
I know.
But this was actually a headset.
I thought that maybe...
I knew nothing about mics or anything like that, so I thought that maybe having a headset would be fine audio quality.
But...
For...
I don't remember what mic I used.
I think I used like the AT2020, which I also still have for my...
And like I use an interface for my intro video.
So...
I don't...
Toaster Mike!
There's probably like no names in this chat.
Wait!
I recognize people!
Toaster Mike!
What does that mean?
There's still some people I recognize.
People are already roasting my mic.
I'm sorry.
Here.
Let me...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
But probably nobody here in this chat watches me or even knows about me anymore.
No.
I'm sorry.
I'm looking at the names.
She sounds so different.
I know, right?
It's kind of crazy.
Hello.
ASMR.
I don't...
I...
I found you a little later.
I never thought about doing ASMR.
Honestly.
I don't know...
This is like...
This...
Okay.
You guys.
This is my first...
This is my introduction to...
To everybody.
This is my introduction stream!
Also 200 people at my debut.
I had 200 people at my debut.
I'm nervous as heck.
I was there.
Los arurus!
Gracias!
But 200 people watching me on my debut.
And it was so much.
It was so much.
My little ghost heart couldn't handle it.
This is my first introduction.
I'm making a fool of myself, truly.
I can't really do it seriously.
The mic sounds different from the trailer.
I can't believe there's so many people in here.
The mic I'm using now is a different mic from my video.
I sound so sad.
Wait.
So apologetic back then.
Now she openly hates us.
Wait, wait.
No!
Was that a donation?
What?
No, no, no.
I kind of... the old donation sound is so nostalgic.
Was that a donation?
Was that a super chat?
Oh my gosh!
Alina, thank you so much for the hookers over there.
Thank you.
Wait, maybe that makes it a little spooky, right?
Right?
A dead mic?
I don't even know how to sound like this anymore.
There's so many people.
Donation.
No, no, no.
So cute.
A little gif.
Not me.
No, don't.
No, no, no.
Okay, I can't deal with this anymore.
Please continue forward.
Okay, so I know I answered some marshmallows and stuff.
Let's see what questions people asked of me.
Oh.
This one was if I worked at the Scarlet Devil Mansion.
Kawaii.
Saiko kawaii.
Really.
Marshmallow.
So, uh, yes.
I would work there.
What?
Photos.
0, 3, 7, E, 1, 9, 0, 5, 8, 5, 2, D, 4, 1, 7, E, B, F, F, A, 1, B, F, 0, 1, D, 6, 8, 6, 6, 9, 8.
That PNG.
The main mint shirt I ordered in mint color just showed up!
Oh my god!
Let's go.
I was given a 4 hour work commute this week and I've been listening to the podcast during the drive so I wanted to say thank you to you and Manta for saving my life.
Oh my gosh, Serval.
Stop.
But good luck with your drive and everything.
4 hour work commute.
That's insane.
Working at the STM?
That's for fairy maids though, not you?
Hey.
I could.
This is soul.
Let's see, what other questions?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
PC.
I sound so quiet!
People are gonna listen to this.
You guys are gonna listen to this and be like, where'd she go?
What happened to her?
My gaming laptop?
So, I didn't really play a lot of games on PC so I played more on console.
Is it quiet though?
Can you hear it?
Actually, probably better you can't.
Oh my god, I can hear my laptop.
Oh, I see other people like Touhou.
Yay!
Sakuya's gonna be jealous.
The breathing.
You've changed.
No!
I haven't changed!
Yeah.
Touhou.
You can hear the fuzz, can't you?
Wouldn't you want to work with Yuyuko instead?
Maybe.
But I think Yomu is just...
I think if I were too close to Yomu, I'd be...
I'd die again.
Because she's so cute.
This mic makes me sound so strange.
But my favorite Touhou's actually are Remilia Ojousama.
My favorite Touhou is Remilia Ojousama.
I don't know.
Kokasa.
Yeah.
How do I sound like that?
Um...
What's the game?
How do I sound like that?
UFO?
Yeah, yeah.
Right, yeah.
I sound kinda like a valley girl.
My favorite game is Mountain of Faith.
How do I sound like that?
So...
I would play...
I'd play on my Switch.
And next.
You sound so cute back there.
Okay.
I still sound cute though, right?
How old are you?
I'm forever 19.
How tall are you?
Uh...
I'm about a hundred and thirty-five centimeters.
So...
Thank you so much.
What is that?
Like almost five feet?
Hmm...
Um...
Do you like playing horror games?
No.
But yes.
Happy anniversary.
Thank you.
Are you a gamer?
I'm kind of a gamer.
Is there someone you know in Vtuber?
Like my favorite Vtuber?
Is that what that means?
My favorite Vtuber?
Um...
Because...
I wonder who I answer here.
Favorite of all time?
It's really difficult.
Maybe...
I'm a gamer.
Are you a gamer?
Yeah.
Shiro-chan?
Do you guys know Denou Shoujo Shiro?
Oh!
Denou Shoujo Shiro?
Do you guys know?
Kaguya Luna.
Do you guys know Denou Shoujo Shiro?
I watch...
I actually...
I think probably around this time, I watched a lot of her.
I think her...
Also...
Uh...
Well...
Actually, I don't remember when I first started Himehina.
Yeah.
Yeah, the dolphin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kaguya Luna.
Shiro mentioned.
Wow!
Wait, wait.
I wonder if I mentioned anyone else.
She's so cute.
My emo...
Or my...
Notice just covering my face.
Oh!
Nope.
That's it.
I don't talk about that anymore.
How do I sound like this though?
So, um...
My name is Mint Phantom.
Um...
Hello?
Wait.
I'm sorry.
Hello?
If people reincarnate after their passing, if people, if, if, if people reincarnate after their passing, try to be quiet.
If people reincarnate after their passing...
And, oh, wait, I forgot to...
There was something else.
Oh, thank you you, Mr. Master.
Thank you.
And it's okay.
You didn't ask too much.
Can you do the breathy?
If people reincarnate after their passing, and those who still have something to say, Make your voice softer.
What is your grudge?
So, I actually don't really...
remember much of before I was alive.
I remember.
But I'm saving that for another day!
Saving that for another day, baby.
So, actually, nothing.
I just remember that I...
Fireball bitch!
What's the word?
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I liked idols, and I liked maids.
And so I just brought that with me.
Johnny, thank you so much for the 50!
My grudge?
From what I remember, it's that I never took that one checky with my oshi.
And so, now I'll never be able to take the checky with my oshi!
This is too real.
Why you gotta be like that?
Why are people saying small?
Me?
Am I small?
No, no, no.
I am not small.
I am ghost.
She's so real!
Hello, miss.
If it's not a rude question to ask a lady, when and how did you become a ghost?
She's so me!
The question everyone wants to know.
How did I become a ghost?
I really, like I said, I really don't remember much, but I do remember this.
Little I remember.
No, stop saying small.
I am not small.
No.
Stop saying small.
Do you guys know what a checky is?
A checky is not small, just ghost.
But a checky is a polaroid picture.
Stop saying small.
Very popular at maid cafes and idol concerts.
Yes.
Stop saying small.
How did I die?
How did I become a ghost?
So, you know, I have a regret with not being able to take the checky with my idol and my idol, my very best idol, my kamiyoshi.
My kamiyoshi.
She announced her graduation and so I died of a broken heart.
But now, I can go and haunt maid cafes and idol concerts and they don't really notice me.
But it's sad because I can't take checkies because of it.
So, I get sad.
Old mean tall.
What kind of a ghost am I?
What do you mean?
Old mean tall.
Small.
Stop!
Just ghost.
You're embarrassing me.
Next.
You are one of the cutest ghosts that I am not scared of as long as you don't haunt me.
I haunt you.
I don't know who you are but I'm going to haunt you now.
It's true.
I haunt.
You can't stop it.
My question is, what made you decide to use ghost as an inspiration for your avatar?
You can't stop the haunt.
One second.
I died because of a mint overdose.
Are you guys enjoying this watch along?
You know.
What's my favorite ice cream?
I answer so many things.
I
really like ice cream so maybe cookies and cream.
Yes!
It's true!
That's still the same.
Next.
If you were to serve someone forever, who would it be?
That's a really hard one.
First time I watched it was during an emergency Among Us with Artemis.
Oh wait.
Emergency.
I'm trying to think of like characters that have been a hell of a ride getting your box.
Like maids with them.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Because if they have maids with them like I get it better.
How do I sound like this?
Hello everybody.
You may not know me.
But I know you.
I always just have this like lead paint stare going on.
I just...
Just got that lead paint stare going on.
Why her arms like that?
Could we get over this please?
Staring into our soul.
I can wink.
I can kinda wink.
How does it feel?
How does it feel to be basically back in 2021?
Wait.
How...
How does it feel to be back in 2021?
2020?
2020.
My hands are like this because I'm a ghost.
I'll show you guys my whole model.
I'm not very...
These are my shoes.
Look at that.
I can't really move so much because back... Look at my skirt barely flows at all.
My legs barely flow at all.
Back then...
You know, Vtubers were stiff people.
We were stiff, stiff as a board.
And um...
You can see...
I can barely move.
I'm so, so stiff.
Do before... after comparison.
Actually...
How do I do that?
Hold on.
There is a way.
One second.
Hold on.
There's a thing I can do.
Actually, I think I can do this.
Maybe.
Uh...
Chat, hold!
Crazy what four years can do to a Vtuber.
I know, right?
But um...
Let's see.
If I do this...
Um...
This?
Actually, give me one second.
I'm gonna disappear again.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Never mind.
I don't need to disappear.
I can do this.
Okay.
How do I do this?
Guys, I'm a little confused.
I don't know how things work, okay?
Um...
Uh...
Let's just play the video while I figure it out.
Understanding of how they would treat their maids.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for being born.
Chuchuchu.
Samara style.
But...
Not born.
I don't know who I would...
Who I would...
Sorry, I'm laughing reading your comments.
I do like...
I do like mint ice cream.
I do, I do.
But cookies and cream.
No, my name is...
My name is mint.
Don't change my name.
Don't change my name!
That's all I have.
What do they change it to?
Cookies and cream?
No, I'm mint.
Subaru?
Would I serve Subaru?
I don't know.
I don't really like Subaru.
I like...
Maybe I'll serve Rem.
I'll serve Rem forever because then she could understand what it's like to have someone serve her.
And appreciate her.
And not dump her like Subaru does.
So true.
Stupid.
How dare he.
What an idiot.
I cannot believe.
Have you seen her face?
Have you seen how cute she is?
So, we'll say Rem.
I'll serve Rem Ojousama forever.
Rem Ojousama.
My favorite drink?
Well, I said bubble tea.
But specifically...
Specifically...
Specifically mango.
Mango green tea.
I really like it.
I love mango green tea.
Gosh, who is this girl?
She's so based.
I died falling from a cliff because she was so small to grab the railings.
I'm not that small.
I'm really...
It's true though.
I'm really not that small.
Thank you, Hayato.
Thank you for coming.
So, favorite drink?
Mango green tea.
I think I do it like this.
What are some of the things that scares you, Minto-san?
Uh... ghosts.
True?
True.
Well, ghosts...
And also...
Actually, I don't want to admit that.
I'll just say bugs.
There's a specific kind of bug.
And it's so silly.
So I won't say it.
Wait, I don't even know what I'm talking about here.
I wonder if it's...
Thank you everyone who has come so far.
So...
I wonder if it's ladybugs.
Because I am afraid of ladybugs.
Have you ever seen Yuna in the Haunted Hot Springs?
Yes, I have.
And I really love her.
Okay, I think I got it.
She's got a nice body.
So true.
So, um...
Double Minto!
Hi, hello, Minto-chan.
I want to ask...
Which country do you like slash want to travel to?
Triple Minto!
A country that I want to travel to...
Oh my god.
I've never been to Europe.
So I want to travel all over Europe.
I still haven't been.
I think.
I sound so different.
No bully in the chat.
You guys liked me before.
Now you're just like...
Now you like your voices too.
No...
Hold on.
How do I...
No bully.
No bully in the chat.
I don't feel like I can do it.
I don't feel like I could...
I think it's also the...
The mic too, right?
Probably...
You like my current voice?
You do?
It's okay?
Part of it is definitely the mic.
I wonder...
Let's see.
I just answer questions.
This whole thing.
Oh my gosh!
Hold on.
What's going on here?
Afraid of ladybugs?
Poor Berry.
It's kind of funny that she's a ladybug because I am afraid of them.
Okay, hold on.
Let's do that.
Play.
Oh.
The...
The audio is...
The BGM is so much louder than my...
Than my voice, you know?
I'm so indecisive.
Am I streaming from laptop?
Yes.
I think everybody knows.
Okay.
We'll have an official name.
And then we'll have fandom.
I was gonna say we'll have a dumb name.
It's iconic.
Never doubt yourself, my ghoul friend.
It's a doggy dog world.
So true!
How did they know that I was streaming from my laptop?
Make a tweet, make a tweet.
Oh!
My arms!
Um...
I tweet.
Up, up, up, up.
Make a tweet, make a tweet.
I tweet.
Big busts.
Your favorite.
Uh, uh, favorite.
And redacted dust.
They phased out of existence.
Oh, they come back eventually.
But I haven't watched it.
Oh, and then I also have...
These guys, look.
I've only read the manga.
I've never watched the show.
So, don't hate me.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Oh, look.
I think people used to call these fart clouds.
I have little, little ghost friends.
Master!
Oh my gosh.
Proto-wisps.
I know, right?
Master.
Thank you for the question.
Thank you.
So cool.
Thank you, thank you.
I had three... I had three wisps.
At all times.
Four would have been maybe a little spookier, right?
But, let's see.
Anything else that happens?
No.
Literally, that's it.
How does it end?
How do I end the stream?
Thank you for watching.
I'm so happy.
Thank you.
Thank you for your hard work.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Four, four, four.
So spooky.
One more donation.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Do you guys miss when I call you Master?
Bye-bye.
Kind of like say it just at the beginning.
Okay.
One, two, three.
Bye.
Okay.
Three
seconds.
It's over.
No way.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see if there's anything else.
Any other streams and stuff.
I'm not going to go through like you know a ton of them or anything like that.
Oh here.
I'll get rid of the menu too.
Wow.
It's really like I'm just back in the day baby.
One of the first...
The first thing I played ever was Witch's House.
Which is a...
You know that... What's it called?
Game.
The pixel game?
Pixel game.
First...
Stop.
But what did I do for other streams?
Okay.
I'm going to go to my very next stream.
We'll do the Witch's House.
How did I end the stream though?
Right?
First Moi Moi game stream.
If you guys have noticed my...
Or maybe you haven't noticed but my...
My...
My playlists are all kind of similar to how they were back then.
So my playlists are like...
Hold on.
I'm pulling it up so I can remember too.
I have like...
Moi random hauntings.
Which this stream is in.
I have Mint's Moi Moi gaming.
Moi membership streams.
Moi collab streams.
Moi karaoke streams.
Moi spirit box sessions.
You know like... Everything is so Moi Moi.
Yeah.
Everything is Moi Moi Moi Moi.
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
You can't see.
The amount of likes on this one!
Oh.
Wait.
That's why you can't see.
Not because I'm blocking it.
Because you can't see it.
Small.
Look at this.
Look.
4-4-4!
How spooky is that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
So I started...
Oh!
I
don't even have a starting screen.
I just jump right into it, baby.
You can hear me breathing.
Can you guys see me?
Hello.
Why do I sound so sad?
And the breathing is...
This is the best overlay ever.
The game is just clipping into my...
Into my...
My...
What's the word?
Logo!
Just...
I don't know how this...
This...
What this chat is.
I don't even know.
Am I here?
So...
Oh, at some point, look.
Some ghosties come out.
Just look.
Let's see.
I just want to know how I end the stream.
Do I have a closed...
I don't think so, you guys.
I think I just end the stream.
You guys, I think I just end the stream as I did before.
Yay!
What the...
What was that?
Why was this...
It's the other...
It's...
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Why am I so low energy?
I feel so like...
Okay, we're gonna listen to Bustin' now.
Okay.
Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Oh...
Maybe I have changed more than I thought that I have.
Probably nervous.
I think so too.
OL work.
I wasn't...
I was tired from being an OL.
I was tired from being an office lady, so I was just...
Sad.
I was just so sad.
I'm sorry.
Hold on.
I'll move this too.
I don't know how high my heart-rate has gotten.
It's true though.
It's so true.
But...
But... I really liked streaming so I did as much as I could back then.
I
loved it !
I loved it !
INFP We did this on the podcast!
Cast.
Wait, let me ask Matora.
What am I?
What... what am I?
L... L... M... N... O... P. 51 cards!
Thank you for the... What happened to my face?
What happened to my face?
How do I change it back?
I fixed it.
I fixed it, I fixed it, I fixed it.
Past Minto is haunting us.
I don't know if you guys have ever seen... I think... hold on.
I think it's this.
Oh wait.
I'll have to try later.
I'm not manifesting enough ghost power.
She's got such a thousand-yard stare.
It's true!
I'm just kinda...
I watched a video recently about... do you guys know the movie?
I've never watched it as a kid, but it's called The Indian in the Cupboard.
And it's about this kid that gets like a little toy and he puts it in his cupboard and it comes to life.
But the kid always has this thousand-yard stare.
He's just like...
Just like this.
I wish... wait.
I wonder if I can make my Mintos look at each other.
Okay, Minto.
We're gonna... hold on.
One second.
We're gonna have you look at each other.
Mintos.
You're over there.
One second.
You come over here.
Hi, Minto!
Hello there, Minto.
How are you doing today?
I'm great.
Thank you, Minto.
Now, kiss?
Self-love.
Thank you, Miss First!
You're generally such an amazing person.
So proud to see you shining today.
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
Imagine putting an anime figure in the cupboard.
I know.
What?
Okay.
If you could put one thing in the cupboard...
But... only one.
Only one thing.
What would you put in your cupboard to turn into real?
What would you put in your cupboard?
A Gundam.
Minto.
No, you don't have that.
You don't have that.
A jar containing a ghost.
Whiskey?
What?
That doesn't make any sense.
I know.
Minto Stanley.
Okay.
I'm getting a little freaked out that Minto is staring at me.
So we're just gonna...
We're gonna...
Fix it.
There we go.
Well, I don't know what...
I guess I... I thought really truly that I was like, I haven't changed so much.
Since I... since I was around... since like I first started streaming, but...
I've actually have changed so much.
Way more than I ever realized.
Especially my voice.
Like, that's kinda crazy.
Hold on.
I'm seeing if there's anything else that I've played or done or whatever.
She's so different.
Oh, yeah.
I wonder.
Let's see like a...
Oh, I have a 4.44 sub karaoke stream.
Let's see how my singing is.
Let's see.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
This might actually be...
This might actually be unbearable.
Hold on.
4.44k subs.
You've gotten way more confident.
Okay, okay, okay.
Surely, this is 3 years ago.
Surely at this point I have a... an opening...
Oh!
It's the one that I use now!
And a closing.
Okay, okay.
Alright, here we go.
My opening sound...
Is just the joy sound.
Where's the music?
You can't hear it?
Is it too soft?
Like that?
Yeah, it's like...
It's the joy sound music.
My birthday coincidentally.
Happy birthday, Ethan!
Oh my goodness.
It's always something.
These are so funny.
Here, let's skip a little ahead.
What did I sing?
What did I sing back in the day?
I'm gonna skip... here.
Wait, I sang the...
... Recently.
Recently.
And then this is a Conan song, Nazo, and then Fanta.
Wait, what's this one?
What is happening?
Why is it Legend of Zelda background?
Connect, part of your world, Mario, Pokemon edition.
Oh wait.
What is this?
What is the background?
Oh my god!
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
Mint of the past was so brave.
No reverb, nothing.
Just regular...
Regular...
Fake Nate!
You're there!
There you are!
And Cosmo, you're there too!
Raw dog.
Stop!
Don't say that!
Oh my gosh.
Isaruru!
There you are!
But...
Oh
my gosh!
I feel like I've seen F.W.A.S.T.
around, but maybe I'm gaslighting myself.
Salute to the old heads.
Mewtwo.
Let's see.
What else is here?
What's this one?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Did I actually sing Fancy Baby Doll?
Da da da da da da da.
This is Trendsing Pulse.
Maybe nothing has changed.
Maybe I need to learn new songs.
Maybe I need to learn new stuff in four years.
Mado!
Mado kime...
Yay!
Ikenai Borderline was that old?
Wow.
What are you talking about?
Ikenai Borderline...
I think was a couple years even before I debuted.
Sorry, OBS is being weird.
Sorry, sorry!
Okay.
I think...
I don't know, is there anything else you guys want to see of my old streams?
I think we got the idea, haven't we?
Fukashigi no Karte!
Ta-da!
Oh, this is Snow Halation.
I just recently put out a short of this song.
Show Yomawari?
What, like the end of Yomawari?
Okay guys, this is when I first ever lost it.
Hold on.
This is when I first ever lost it on stream.
Wait.
Yomawari...
Three?
How many parts did it take me to beat this game?
I don't see anymore.
It must be three.
Must be three.
This one.
Moi moi game stream.
But it wasn't very moi moi, I think.
I think actually...
Let's see, I was fighting the final boss.
Hold on.
Did I beat it?
Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Joshua, thank you!
Here we go.
First time I ever lost it.
Maybe here.
Oh.
Friendly video, is that okay?
Is that okay if this becomes my...
Whoa!
What happened to the quality?
There we go.
So from the walkthrough it says to circle around the edge...
How long was I on this fight for?
A long time.
Oh gosh, this is giving...
This is just too...
Oh my gosh.
How was I on this fight?
Okay, started around 1.38...
And I'm at 2.37!
So I've been on it for an hour.
This fight is actually super hard.
I wonder how well I would do now.
Okay.
Maybe I'll try to still be nice.
Whoa!
But if I let something slip, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
When did I really start losing it?
I wish I could see the comments.
Same winter noises.
After this, I'm going to...
Oh yeah.
After this, I'm going to announce some...
Oh my god.
Girlie!
I'm going to announce some stuff, so...
What the mid-ception?
YouTube's policy is really dumb for that.
Because they make everyone conform...
What am I talking about?
...to children, even if you...
Conform to children?
...say your channel isn't for children.
Oh!
Like, obviously this game is not for children.
But if I don't swear it's monetized, what sense does that make?
You know?
Oh, I'm...
Yeah, go off.
Go off, Pashmint.
Oh, no!
You had it!
And then I'm still fighting on my thumbnail.
Remember the thumbnail I told you about earlier?
That's the one I was still fighting about.
They kept demonetizing my stream because of it.
Don't whitelist my thumbnail.
Because there's no reason
for my thumbnail.
Happy late...
What do you mean late first anniversary?
Oh, I guess it is kind of late, right?
To be taken down.
Thank you!
Fight for the booba.
Now you get thumbnails that are even crazier, right?
I don't know how to juke them into...
To go out, you know?
I really...
Come on, please!
When do I start popping off, though?
His pinky touched me.
It went...
Boink!
What am I talking about?
But...
But yeah!
I started with the bottom one, but the top one is the hardest to get.
So, if I get it first...
Oh!
Yeah!
Because I can like...
They're not...
Because they camp up there the most.
It's terrible.
It's absolutely the worst.
It's true.
Pop off, girly.
Pop off.
Peculiar things are the gifted!
Anyway...
Yeah.
I think that's...
That's about everything, isn't it?
I think that's about everything.
Wow.
Look at...
Back in the day...
I don't think I need this heart rate monitor anymore.
Hopefully...
I don't think it got so high.
Maybe...
Maybe I'm normal.
Aren't you gonna show the sleepy ASMR stream?
Sleepy ASMR...
Sleepy ASMR stream?
Hmm?
50 Ikenai borderlines?
Let's see...
Where is that even?
Oh!
Singing Ikenai borderline 50 plus 1 times.
Um...
Oh...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I actually want to see this one too.
When bore...
No...
Uh...
Here...
There...
I become Mikumo.
I become Mintumo.
Wow!
Oh my god!
Different opening!
Cosmo, isn't this the one you made?
Isn't this the one you made?
Oh!
Let's see.
This could be bad.
This could be so bad.
Why is it bad?
Wait.
My hands are like this because I'm a ghost!
Ah!
Paige, thank you!
Toofy, thank you!
Okay.
Thank you!
How
did I go to this one immediately?
Oh my god!
Jeremy!
There you are!
Splatoon!
Ah!
Bloodlust!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Guys, this is how I used to sound like.
Have I improved in my singing a little bit?
Have I improved in my singing?
Or did I regre...
Actually, I feel like I've regressed quite.
Can you hit that note now?
Probably not right now.
Oh!
It must be the new mic.
You peaked here.
I...
Yeah.
I must have...
I've probably regressed.
And so...
I'm so sorry.
You peaked.
Wait.
Voice acting stream!
Practice stream at 1 hour 44 minutes snake.
What?
Wait.
Hold on.
I thought...
What do you...
Wait.
Really?
How did...
Wait.
First of all, how do you have that information?
And second of all...
Where is the voice acting stream?
Voice acting...
Voice acting stream.
Voice...
Voice acting practice stream?
For 1 hour 44 minutes?
I do snake?
You guys!
There is...
There's something I need to share with you guys!
That we need to bring back!
So, there's a video that I really, really love.
I still love it to this day.
I think I... oh gosh, where did I have it saved?
I just have to find where I saved it!
But, basically, it's like... it's about the eagle.
And I must show you guys, for those who don't know.
Maybe those who were here back in the day remember it a little bit.
But if you don't know... where did I save it though?
I don't remember.
Oh no!
No, I found it like the other day!
Is that under here?
No... I'll show you guys.
I'll find it.
The eagle fly higher!
Above the clouds!
Exactly!
Oh wait!
No, these are just random videos.
What are these?
What are they?
Oh, these are just random videos.
Oh, I still have my intro video!
No way!
I still have my intro video.
In here, I have a video of... I think this is a video of Pikami saying my name.
I still have a video... look at this.
I have a screenshot of Pikami when she modded me on her channel.
I can't get rid of it.
It's my precious.
It's my precious... my precious... you know...
And then I have this screenshot as well of me next to Pikami when we were playing Among Us together.
Oh my gosh!
I know I had it though!
I know I had it.
I just can't find it.
What?
Okay, I should have been more prepared.
I'm so sorry you guys.
But I'll find it and I'll show you guys next time I find it.
I'll be like, look, this is one of my favorite videos of all time.
But where did I have it?
Maybe... Oh, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're waiting.
And then we're gonna watch...
No.
I lost.
I don't think so.
No.
Dang it.
Oh, where did I save this at?
Hold!
I don't know where I saved it.
I do have it somewhere though, as you can tell.
I save everything.
I keep everything.
I'm a little freaky like that.
Okay.
So here I'm doing a snake impression.
Let's see.
Oh, Bashamin!
Is she okay?
I don't know what's going on.
I think I'm dying.
Of laughter.
Or just dying.
Again.
Why am I laughing so much?
Wait.
I'm crying.
I think I'm actually crying.
She cries higher.
Above the cloud.
Wait.
Okay.
We're almost to 144.
What's that sound?
It's like a...
Sorry.
Ohamito.
Good morning.
While this plays, I'll also look for it.
The timing.
We'll never know what's so funny.
Next.
I don't see it playing.
What is that?
Sorry in advance.
Can you please say, please say, in solid snake language?
Okay.
No way.
No.
Come on.
You can do this.
I hate it.
I'm gonna do it.
No.
I don't hate this.
I love this.
Hmm.
Colonel.
I'm a child.
It's okay.
You can do it, Mint.
You can do it.
You can do it, me from the past.
The prophecy is true.
Metal Gear has always been a part of me.
How did you know this?
How did you know that this was here?
In this VOD?
How did you know this?
Oh god.
I can't even get through it.
That's so funny.
The sacred text.
I'm dummy thick and the clap of my ass cheeks keeps alerting the guards.
Colonel, I'm trying to sneak around but I'm dummy thick.
It was foretold in the scripts.
Kojumbo does it again.
Free will is a myth?
Let's see.
There was this one I wanted to look at.
Maybe this is the last one that I do.
Because I'm just kind of curious.
It's an Akiba tour.
Which I did an updated version when I first came back.
Oh my goodness.
Please wait to be seated.
Let's see where we're here.
Jonathan's.
This Jonathan's is not there anymore.
This Jonathan's isn't there anymore, I believe.
We need to match that character.
A Goku haircut.
Goku haircut!
You could get a one...
Let's see what else is around.
Mileage!
I don't know how to do that.
Oh wait, is this it?
Oh, we can go back.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, let's go back.
I feel like I'm sensing deja vu right now.
March 2020.
Did it burn down?
No, they just changed the place.
Is this where we talk about Akiba CIA?
That Hotomoto Grill also isn't there anymore, I believe.
Oh, I know.
This is...
Oh, Hanyon!
Hanyon!
Oh my god.
Let's play.
Survival game?
What is this?
I think that's still there though.
Soft...
Wait, wait, wait.
Akiba CIA is right there.
Akiba CIA is like right there, isn't it?
Oh wait, no, never mind.
Meet... meant to meet up at Akiba CIA.
Oh my god!
I have made meet up at Akiba CIA.
Akiba CIA.
The way to the Google person.
Oh my god!
It's not there anymore, unfortunately.
But...
Oh, wow!
It's like some of the smaller things that I remember, you know?
Perfect timing.
Anyways, this is fine.
This is...
A fun trip down memory lane.
I still am confused how you...
Oh my gosh, this stream is just called The Spy Animals Got Me.
Thank
you for the anniversary!
Yeah!
Thank you, Sai!
Thank you.
The Spy Animals Got Me.
It's getting more and more unhinged.
And then...
My review...
And then my announcement...
Reveal this of how I look now.
And then my karaoke plus announcement.
I'm so sorry.
That's why I announced my graduation.
And then I came back.
It's okay.
It's all good.
I came back.
So...
Yeah.
We're here.
We're here now.
As a family.
We're here now as a family.
So...
I have some things I would like to announce.
Um...
Uh...
Some of my...
Well, okay.
So...
I'm still trying to figure out how to open up the store.
And um...
You'll see from the pictures as well.
That some of the stuff is not completed as well.
But...
Um...
There is stuff...
Perhaps that I will...
We will be selling in the future!
Merch!
And I will share with you what the merch will be.
Some of these will be on my own store.
Some of these will be in other locations.
And of course I will spam everywhere where you will be able to get the stuff as soon as it's available.
But I have three...
Three things...
For now.
Yes.
And first, if you were in the membership stream, you will have seen...
Ta-da!
Mint plushie!
Mint!
Official mint plushie that you can take and grab and go on the Minto2go everywhere.
Very throwable, yes, yes.
You can take it anywhere.
You can take all your fun pictures with it.
And all the cool things.
It's about 9 centimeters.
So...
Very portable!
Very squeezable, yes, yes.
Yes.
And...
So...
Here's the back.
One second.
Look at that!
I was supposed to have a sample for...
That was being sent to me today.
I was gonna like show you with my real hands.
But unfortunately...
It didn't arrive on time.
So...
I believe the plushie will be on somebody else's site.
Of course, I will give you all the details.
But the person I've been working with has been so awesome.
I thought maybe it would be done in time.
For today.
To be like...
Like...
It would be in my...
Like the inventory would be in my possession.
But...
Actually, the vendor...
The designer and everything.
They spent a really long time trying to find someone that would do the gradient in my hair.
Which is really nice because...
I like that part.
And so they worked really hard to...
To...
Here, I'll zoom...
I'll make it big again so you guys can see.
See it?
It's so cute, isn't it?
It's so grab-able.
So...
I hope you...
Will grab your little mint and...
Grab her and shake her.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Actually, I'll put it like right here.
Ta-da!
So...
I don't quite have a date for when all of these...
There will be pre-orders first as well.
They won't be like...
They won't be...
Like...
So you will probably have to wait some time before you get them.
I'm really sorry.
But...
I will get it to you eventually.
And I don't...
I'm not quite sure of when the shop will open.
When everything will be up as well.
But of course, like I said, I'll post it on the community tab.
I'll post it on Twitter.
I'll have it on the menu.
It will be...
Everywhere.
That you...
That I can post it.
So yeah.
Eventually.
I'm looking to ship...
Wherever I can.
For...
The stuff that I will be shipping out myself.
I planned to be doing international.
But again...
I'm working stuff out.
So...
Yes.
Doing everything myself.
So you know.
Antarctica.
Let's go.
But yeah.
So plushy.
The next thing.
This actually...
I believe it was announced right before stream.
But I have...
Oh my gosh.
The picture is humongous.
One second.
Ta-da.
Ta -da.
An official mint happy.
Happy.
Yeah.
Official mint happy.
Akiba's custom made.
And...
The art is by Maru.
And it's got my signature down there.
And...
This...
This will not be on my store.
But it will be...
Also maybe...
Available at certain conventions.
Like...
If...
If the vendor will be at the convention as well.
So...
Yeah.
The art is really really cute.
I love the design.
I like how it's like...
Kind of spooky.
And...
And soft.
And the chocolate.
And the wisps.
And everything.
They're so cute.
So...
And the little gravestones.
Everything.
I love...
I love it so much.
So...
Yeah.
The tombstones are unexpectedly metal.
So yeah.
That will be...
On sale eventually.
I don't think Otakutan will be...
I don't think it will be done in time for Otakutan unfortunately.
But...
I would say...
For mostly everything...
Within...
By...
I would say...
End of the year.
Which I know it's kind of early to be...
Announcing...
Oh wait.
Let me make this small as well too.
And then...
I know it's kind of early to be announcing.
But...
I'm going to be announcing it.
And then being like...
Oh yeah.
You'll get it by the end of the year.
But...
You know.
Merch stuff takes a while to create.
And things like...
And things like that.
So...
Um...
Mm-hmm.
I appreciate your patience.
It's also my first time ever like making merch.
So...
It's been...
It's been a very...
Learning curve.
It's been an...
It's been a...
A learning curve for sure.
Yeah.
Um...
The next thing...
Okay.
I'm going to move the notifs again.
Put you over here.
Um...
The next thing...
I have...
Is...
Uh...
Okay.
So this one you'll see of course...
That it's not done.
It's still in...
The sketch phase.
But...
Um...
It is...
Will be...
I don't know.
Completed eventually.
But...
Um...
Oh gosh.
I'm kind of nervous about this one.
I actually...
I censored...
No.
I didn't censor it.
I...
Since it's a sketch...
I didn't want...
And the design is not final.
I kind of blurred it just a little bit.
Ta-da!
Mint dakimakura!
As you can see...
I'm going to...
Um...
Onii-chan daisuki!
Thanks for the buy!
Get it!
Um...
Yep!
The dakimakura.
You can see the side A and the side B.
And um...
It's so funny because...
The artist is Deyui.
And uh...
It's so blurred.
We can't see the moles.
I can kind of see it.
Maybe...
Maybe you can't.
I can kind of see it.
But they are there.
Um...
I had a different image in mind for the back side.
And Deyui was just like...
I think...
We need to go beyond.
I was like...
Here hold on.
I'm going to...
There we go.
So you can see me.
I'm embarrassed.
You're seeing old Mint.
She can stay behind me.
Like a go...
Like she's haunting me.
There we go.
I'm embarrassed.
Um...
So...
You can thank Deyui...
For...
For the back side.
Which I don't hate.
I still think it's pretty cute.
But um...
She has a stand.
Jojo!
Um...
Back side...
Best side...
Any estimated pricings yet?
I wish I could tell you.
Um...
Unfortunately I don't have anything set in stone.
But...
Once it gets closer to everything I will of course...
Um...
Tell you guys.
Probably...
You know...
I...
Um...
The Daki...
You know...
Probably be like normal Daki rates.
So...
Table dom!
Thank you for the tenget and thank you!
But yeah.
So...
My own Daki makura.
It's a little...
It's a little spicy!
It's...
But um...
Um...
I hope you guys will still like it.
The other stuff is wholesome, so you know.
The spice of life.
Mint is basically a spice.
It's so embarrassing showing off something like this.
And there were even versions that were even spicier.
Than version C.
There were versions that I was like...
I don't think we can go this...
I don't think we can go this far.
There were...
The
pig!
I still remember finding your Ace Attorney finale stream in the middle of the night 3 years ago.
Oh my gosh, Pogman.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
How about B and A?
A was the spiciest... no, B was the spiciest.
I'm not gonna show you guys.
Because then you'll be like...
This is what we could've had!
I'm not gonna show you guys.
Release the day we cut.
She hates us!
Show the director's cut!
Happy anniversary, Mintou.
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Notorious!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
PSG.
Oh my gosh.
I'm giving it the peer pressure right now.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on!
Hold!
I'll get it.
But I'm gonna hide.
Because I'm embarrassed.
So...
I think my channel...
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh god.
So...
Just to...
I'm just gonna...
The comments are so funny that they wrote because this is just says, Emphasize ass.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
This is not what it will be.
Obviously.
But...
This is...
This is one of the...
This is what they sent me.
And I was like...
Um...
I don't... I don't know about this one, chief.
Oh gosh, oh gosh!
OK, OK.
I'm disappearing.
OK, go, go, go, go, go away!
Anyway...
That was one of the sketches.
Too spicy for TV, true.
Way too spicy, way too spicy.
And the last thing that I have is...
Something that I think is kind of fun.
Because...
I've been so excited about this.
Maybe it's not the most exciting thing.
But I've been very excited about it.
Because...
I don't see very many people having merch like this.
So...
And I think you guys will find it fun as well.
So a couple of months ago, a company reached out to me.
And... the Japanese company.
And at first, I was like nervous about responding.
I was just like, oh...
I don't know...
Can I work with them?
Because, you know, the language barrier and...
Working with Japanese company, this and that.
But...
I kind of got over my fear.
And I was like, you know what?
No.
I will.
I will contact them.
And so, I even hired a translator to work with me.
And we've been going back and forth.
And they've been so kind.
And so...
So...
Fun to talk to and work with.
It's not...
It's not the most impressive thing, maybe.
And it's maybe not what you guys think.
Who's saying Tenga?
Where did this come from?
Huh?
No!
It's wholesome!
Stop!
It's wholesome.
But...
So, again...
I think I'm...
You know...
Maybe it's not so impressive, like I said.
But...
To me, it's been a lot of work that I've been putting into it.
So...
To me, it feels a little bit more special.
But basically, the...
One second...
The...
The company is called...
Mitako Block.
Mitakuru Block.
And we've been working together to create...
Da da da...
Oh, wait...
Uh...
Da da da...
Da da da da...
Ta-da!
Lego Mito!
It's your...
You...
You know how, like, there's, like, the Pokemon, like, little Legos and things like that?
And...
So, I thought, I really like those.
And I even have, like, a Neptunia one.
So, when I got this offer, I was like...
This is so cute!
I can have my own!
And then you will get the pieces and you get to assemble it yourself.
So...
You can have your own little...
Mint DIY project.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Like the Nano Block.
So...
I thought...
I thought this was kind of, like, a fun little...
Fun little thing that you can also...
Put together.
It's...
It's quite small.
I think it's like...
Three inches...
It's like, you know...
It's quite small.
So...
You can put it on your desk.
You can put it on your bookshelf.
You know...
You can put it wherever you...
Wherever you want.
Small.
Small, small, small.
So, yeah.
How does it taste, though?
Like...
Plastic, probably.
Three inches isn't small.
Yes!
It's versatile.
And it's...
Portable!
It's portable!
So...
Yeah!
I was...
I've been really excited about it.
Um...
Uh...
They...
They were just like...
Just...
You know...
Make sure you tell them that it'll be shipped out in this amount of time.
And...
And so...
Um...
Uh...
I imagine...
I'll probably get them around...
Uh...
Around...
Um...
Uh...
Some...
End of August, maybe?
So...
Uh...
We're working on getting it shipped out to me.
All the pieces.
Um...
Oh!
I also want to mention...
That...
Um...
Uh...
So...
For...
Um...
The little LEGO pieces...
The...
The mythical block ones...
Sorry.
I probably shouldn't say LEGO because that's like...
That's like copyrighted, isn't it?
Um...
It is going to be...
Limited.
Uh...
But...
For all of this...
Probably...
You know...
Um...
We can do multiple runs.
I'm not sure how much of stuff we'll sell.
So...
Um...
I'm just kind of...
Seeing...
I'm testing the waters...
To get an idea...
Of...
What...
What to expect...
Um...
But yeah!
Legally distinct block toy.
Um...
Uh...
So yeah!
Um...
I hope you guys...
L...
Like...
The stuff...
Um...
The merch...
My first ever...
Well...
I guess if you don't count the...
Um...
My first ever solo merch launch...
Because...
The Patreon was with Matara...
Or...
Not sorry...
The Patreon...
The podcast was with...
Matara...
But it's my first ever...
Personal...
It's my first ever time...
Like...
Doing my own merch...
And...
Um...
Uh...
There's...
There's more...
Coming in the future as well...
So if you're just like...
Um...
I'm already...
I'm...
I am in talks with...
Perhaps...
Some other places as well...
So...
Um...
Uh...
But...
You know...
Um...
Yes...
It's...
It's kind of...
There's some things that...
Um...
I...
I also didn't want to...
I didn't want to...
Um...
Start off too much...
And overwhelm myself...
Me from three years ago...
Would have been so jealous...
We got mint merch...
Oh my gosh...
Paperbacks!
Thank you for the Onkosupa!
Thanks for being here...
And being silly with us...
Thank you...
Um...
Oh...
But yeah...
Take my money...
No!
Thank you!
Mint from three years ago would die looking at that...
I'm already dying...
Not gonna lie...
I'm kind of just like...
Maybe it's a little outside my comfort zone...
But um...
But...
You know...
I'm not a freak phantom for nothing, right?
Oh...
There we go...
Not freak phantom for nothing...
Haha...
The pre-orders for all this stuff, probably will have pre-orders open sometime next month.
And then the orders will be shipped out a few months from then.
I hope you guys don't mind me being slow and I appreciate your patience with everything.
And all that, Official Freak Phantom Glasses win!
I appreciate you guys always being so patient with me and everything.
How many plushies can I buy?
People say that they are going to buy an amount, but they don't actually...
They're just kidding, you know?
So...
As for the plushies, I definitely think multiple runs will be okay.
Hold on...
But you know, if you...
I'm not kidding!
If you don't buy anything, that's totally okay too.
You know, just being here watching is always more than enough.
Just having your support...
Thank you!
Oh, Spooky!
Thank you so much, Akira!
Thank you!
Okay, here's a tip too!
And yeah...
So, of course, I always...
I always appreciate just any sort of support.
You watching, watching the VODs...
Donating merch...
Whatever, whatever, whatever...
I'm buying a bigger jar!
Jason!
Thank you for the 10!
Thank you so much!
Don't give your money to me, give your money to Yuu-chan!
What are you doing?
Give your money to Yuu-chan!
But...
Yeah!
I don't really know what else.
Sorry that I didn't have so much prepared.
Thank you too!
Thank you!
And...
I'm going to buy even more plushies than before.
No, please!
I don't know how much they're going to be.
Stop saying sorry.
Okay...
Sorry!
I'm sorry for saying sorry!
I'm going to eat some food real quick because I'm starting to get a little hungry.
Spite is powerful.
You know what?
That is true.
I think I'm just mostly...
I just feel so...
Okay, hold on.
It's time to get sappy.
Hold on.
I'm going to turn the sappy music on.
I already feel the tears rising up in my...
I already feel my tears rising up.
Rise of the tears.
Where is my music?
Wait...
Oh, here we go.
This one maybe?
Okay.
Hold, Mint!
Hold!
I already, you know, I feel already so grateful.
That metal tear rising up.
That you guys are here.
And that you guys are watching at all.
And that...
It's been...
I don't want to say tumultuous time.
Basically, I left.
And I came back maybe...
somewhat different.
I don't know what you're talking about.
But...
But, uh...
Oh, now I do have an idea.
You know, so many people here that are, um, even, uh, uh, still, um, sorry, um, still willing to give me a chance, um, uh, sorry.
It was just, it's been kind of a crazy year, and so I'm really happy that I could finally celebrate my anniversary, even though I'm three years late, and I'm sorry I couldn't celebrate it before, and maybe there are people here that didn't watch me before,
so, um, now I'm glad that we could, um,
uh, instead celebrate it all together.
Are those keys?
Are those keys to Metal Gear Solid?
No way, are you just, oh, thank you for reminding me.
I can't believe you just gave away keys for the game, yes.
Uh...
YouTube recommended me one of your streams way back, but I was a hater.
You were a hater?
That's okay.
I would be a hater, too.
You see cringe, uh, cringe, cringe anime.
Girl, do wish I could have stayed a member all three years.
Why, how could I do that, though?
How could I just have my memberships open for all that time?
But, um...
Uh...
Oh my gosh!
Tom!
Happy anniversary, boss!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I used your thing for the stream!
I was like, your, your thing for VTube Studio!
I was like, oh my gosh, Tom developed this?
That's crazy!
Thank you!
Um...
I recently found the channel, but glad to have found you, man!
Thank you!
Love for Metal Gear is strong!
Frank Hunter!
Um...
Huh?
Tom!
I'm so happy to see you again.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Until now.
I'm on my day.
Um...
You know...
Even if you find me today...
Even if you're just like...
Even if you're like, I just came upon this stream and this ghost seems kind of cool and kind of funky!
You know, appreciated that too and...
I just, uh...
I just, uh, I just, I just am so grateful that, um...
You guys haven't given up on me...
I can keep haunting you guys for some time and maybe I should just say it I've kind of have been I have been I have been kind of like I mean things have been I've been slow because I... I... I've been trying to decide what to do.
I've been trying to decide what to do with everything.
But I think... I think I've found my footing a little bit.
A little bit.
And even... I will say this.
I will give a hint.
Even if my appearance changes just a little bit.
Just... a little bit.
Not too dramatic.
I hope that you guys will still...
Still...
Hint phantom.
I hope you guys will still stick around.
But that's not for a while.
Um...
Surgery?
No!
I just... I... I don't know.
I can't...
I just... can't... really thank you guys enough.
3.0?
What's going on?
I think you guys... I think you guys might like the change too.
A little bit.
Like I said, it's not a huge change.
Um...
Not a huge change.
You'll see when it happens.
Um...
BBL?
BBL confirmed?
I'm a newer fan.
Oh no!
Thank you Jose!
Thank you!
2.5?
2.5 I think is a good way to put it.
Um...
We're getting a BBL.
That's my next thing.
I'm going to Brazil!
Brazil!
Um...
I still... and I... um...
I guess I apologize so much because, you know, I feel that you guys have...
Um...
You guys have changed my afterlife.
You guys have changed my whole world.
And um...
All I want for you guys is... um...
Is to...
You know...
For you guys to...
Um...
Also...
Receive, you know...
In whatever ways that I can give.
I feel like... I'm just like...
How... How is merch any special because you're just spending money?
But I... um...
I just wish I could...
Give you guys... uh...
Give you guys back... like...
Fifty-fold!
Everything that, um...
You have done for me, so...
Get
that BBL!
And so, even if, uh...
Even, um...
My birthday...
Or sincere feelings...
Um...
Yeah, you do.
Yeah...
Yeah, I wanna watch you cry...
Before I start streaming.
But yeah... so...
Um...
Never got to appreciate our time in the past.
I'm glad to have another chance!
Thank you!
We have to pay you back tenfold, 500 fold!
What are you talking about?
I always... sorry.
I always feel bad because I just feel like...
You guys do so much for me and I...
Can't ever...
I can't ever repay it...
Like well enough.
I just...
So that's why I'm always just like, I'm sorry.
Because I just really...
I'm really so thankful.
I'm really so grateful for...
You know...
Being in this position.
And...
Like I feel like I'm just...
I'm just the luckiest...
I'm the luckiest ghost ever.
To ever exist.
Ever to exist.
So...
Sorry I'm such a crybaby today.
Like I said, it's been kind of a year.
And so...
It's been...
It's been a year.
And...
Even when I'm a little lonely, you guys...
Never...
Make me feel lonely, so...
Just kind of like...
Sometimes you're allowed to be a big sap.
What...
I'm a leaf!
Mint is a leaf!
Mint is not a tree!
Sap hours...
I'm not really good at...
I...
Expressing myself sometimes.
Especially because when I do...
I turn into the puddle like this.
You can repay us by getting an oil rig and starting a PMC!
Yeah!
We'll start a PMC.
I'm not a words guy, but you're a pretty cool ghost.
Oh, I'm a cool ghost.
We're diamond wisps.
You guys are always...
I think you guys make me laugh more than...
I make you guys laugh.
Private Minto Company.
Yeah!
Mint boss.
Private maid company!
Perfect!
Wait, what does this...
What does the...
Oh, wait.
It's usually private military company, right?
Honor to serve you, boss.
No!
I'm the maid!
I'm serving you!
Oh, contractor.
Contractor.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you, Kuya.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you so much.
Pervert maid company.
Get out.
You know what?
Never mind.
I'll take it back.
But life's a little boring if you're not a pervert.
Isn't it true?
You gotta be a little perverted.
I think life is more fun that way.
So true, ghost.
Do not scatter our ectoplasm to the heartless sea.
No.
I'll eat it.
The fact that you're here with us celebrating now is better than any merch money goodbye.
But if you want to grab something, a reminder that Virtual Vacation merch is now available online.
It's true, actually.
If you didn't go to...
If you didn't go to Virtual Vacation, if you want the...
Oh my god, stop.
Stop, Luhun!
Stop!
Oh my gosh, thanks for the rainbow!
Oh my god.
I have the...
Luhun made some little keychains, right?
Some mint keychains.
And I still have the form.
I still have the model thing that you gave me.
And I'm like, how can I create my own mint army?
Mintification.
My little tiny mint army.
You always make my day, boss.
Thanks.
Thank you.
You guys always make my day too.
I mean that.
Yeah.
Which is why I always...
You know.
I want you to be so happy.
So healthy.
And I want you guys to have fun.
And if...
If your days are bad...
You know.
You can always come to Minto's dream.
And have a good time.
I hope.
If I can at least make you laugh just a little bit.
But...
She doesn't hate us.
Real.
Always remember.
Wait.
Happy Minto Day.
But...
I suck at words.
But I think you are pretty good.
Those are the best words I could hear.
You are pretty good.
Oh my god.
What is this one now?
What is this one?
Here is a sign of my affection.
Outer Wilds meant a lot to me.
It means a lot to you too.
So for chat.
Outer Wilds means so much to me.
Yeah.
Sometimes chat is my oshi.
And I like to give every super chat a like after reading.
That's so wholesome.
I give that a like.
It won't let me like it normally.
But it will let me heart it.
I do have some giveaways as well.
But...
I'm not sure how to give them away.
So you guys might know.
That I have a code.
With gamersubs.
But...
Today...
They asked if I wanted some codes.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the...
They said if I wanted some codes.
And basically...
They gave me...
Hold on.
Um...
Uh...
I thought it was gonna be like...
Oh, here's a code for...
40% off.
No, no.
They gave me some crazy codes.
I just don't know how to get rid of them.
They gave me...
5 codes for $40.
3 codes for $60.
And 1 code for $100 off.
And none of the codes expire.
Yeah.
So...
How do you do giveaways on YouTube?
I don't know!
So...
They actually gave some pretty awesome stuff.
That's crazy.
I know, right?
So...
Big shoutouts to Via.
Thank you.
And Gabersupps.
Thank you so much for providing these codes.
I was so shocked.
I was like...
I thought it was just gonna be like...
Buy code but different.
But no, they gave like real code codes.
So...
Maybe...
What I will do is probably create a Google form.
And you can sign up.
Because obviously I'm going to need like...
Some contact email or something.
For me to send you the...
The codes.
And I will do...
I will pick somebody at random.
And for each one...
Um...
The Hunger Games.
Yeah.
So...
I don't know.
Do you guys want me to do it now?
Or do you want me to...
Maybe I'll do it...
Maybe next stream or something.
I can have the...
The form be up for a certain amount of time.
Because I would want VOD watchers...
To have an opportunity as well.
So I'll have the form up.
And um...
Take your time to get it set up.
Thank you.
After stream.
Yeah.
Because maybe some people are listening to the stream.
And they won't have a chance to enter or anything like that.
So...
I shouldn't be laughing so hard.
Magic doodoo chance.
But um...
VODs deserve a chance.
Of course.
Make an announcement also on Twitter.
I will.
I'll post it everywhere.
So everybody...
Gotta go now.
Thanks 9!
1 year.
Because...
I graduated.
On 4-4.
April 4th.
And then I returned on April 4th.
So it's been 1...
Non-consecutive year.
But overall...
4 years.
It's not about...
Changing the world.
It's about...
Doing our best to make our world a bit better.
Hmm...
Yeah.
Respecting the will of others and believing in your own.
There's only one mint.
But there's room for a lot of wisps.
Thanks boss.
What if instead...
Of the hunger games, it was the freaky games.
Oh my gosh.
What if we all got into...
Got into Minecraft...
And it was just PvP and last one standing won.
Oh my gosh.
What if we crab-gamed it?
What if we...
What if we fall-guys-tortmented?
PvP pervert versus pervert?
Yeah.
Yes.
Marble game.
There will be blood!
Blood!
Shed!
Just for a code.
Hell yeah.
Freaky fall-guys.
May the biggest pervert win!
But yeah.
Thank you guys for...
You know...
Mint may never fulfill all of my wishes.
Yeah.
Maybe that's for the best, right?
Thank you guys...
So much for...
Sorry, I start getting emotional again.
For...
For supporting...
A little ghost like me.
And...
Should go with B after all.
Thanks for accepting me when I'm a little freaky.
When I'm a little shy.
When I'm a little...
When I'm a little ghastly.
Ghostly.
A little freaky.
Yeah.
I hope you guys...
Enjoy the rest of your night.
I thought about maybe going into VRChat.
But I think I gotta go eat instead.
Words hard.
Mint good.
Big heart.
Love forever.
Real freak too.
And all the donations as well.
I know they've been kind of backed up.
From the...
From all the gifted memberships.
I just saw a Snee that you said...
There's a kudo board!
Wait.
My anniversary tag!
Oh my gosh.
I think the...
The viewer count just stabilized.
Oh my god.
I think it's just stable.
Where is...
Oh.
I was like where is it?
It's here.
Hashtag mintiversary.
Wait.
Where do I...
Kudo board.
Oh!
I see it!
Thank you!
Maybe I'll...
Look after stream in case people are still...
I don't know.
Can people still add it to that?
All the bots are gone.
YouTube's been really weird lately.
Thanks for giving me so many laughs.
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
Vengeance.
Get your games everybody.
But if you have the games.
Don't take them from other people.
Trying to see if I can find my first chat.
Ace Attorney vids were my favorite back in the day.
I don't have any plans on...
Un-privating the old VODs.
Because I'm still kind of embarrassed by everything with that.
But...
I...
And also...
I want to make memories with...
With...
With old fans, new fans...
Maybe if you...
Somehow if I haunted you...
Somehow in between...
When I left and when I came back...
I would like to make...
All sorts of memories.
With everybody and...
Have lots of things...
Lots of new memories.
So...
I'm not like...
Abandoning it...
Not saying...
Not saying it never happened.
Just kind of moving forward.
And...
I'll be there no matter what.
Thank you!
Not even un-privating the debut stream.
I don't think we need the debut stream.
I think we...
I think you saw pretty much everything that was the debut stream.
Taco!
Thanks for the 50 gifted!
Thank you guys so much for all the gifted!
If I missed you, I'm so sorry!
Thank you!
I'm reading them as fast as they scroll by.
Free the debut stream.
Maybe I will free the intro video.
Maybe.
Plus pre-ordered.
Thank you!
I feel like I want to say more.
Maybe I should have written it down.
But um...
I have...
too many feelings in my kokoro.
In my heart.
Maybe it's better because I would just cry if I read everything.
So here's to...
hopefully...
many more years?
Hopefully?
And...
Um...
I'll keep...
I'll keep doing my best!
Yeah!
I can't believe also it's been...
I can't believe even that it's been...
That it's been...
4 years.
It's insane to me.
It's so crazy to me.
That thing.
Oh...
Hmm...
Recently started watching and following you, I look forward to your streams or podcasts, Whatever I can make it.
Thank you!
Thanks for finding me.
Thank you, thank you!
I gotta find that video.
I gotta show you guys.
That's one thing from the past we can show.
Thank you!
The anime... the anime fest that I'll be at tomorrow, in Texas, that Ayami-sensei will have merch as well if you're going to be there.
It's exclusive to the event.
Let me see.
Hold on.
Ayami...
She sent it to me earlier.
She was just like...
She was like, oh, I forgot to ask you sooner.
Is it okay if I make merch of us?
I was like, of course!
Let me see.
Hold on.
Anime fest.
This will be at the Sekai Project booth, I believe.
Which will have all of her merch as well if you're going.
But look how cute this is.
Look how cute this is.
Look at this.
Oh, sorry.
My face went whack again.
My bad.
There we go.
Look at this!
Look how cute!
There's a print and an acrylic keychain feature.
Ayami-sensei and me!
Oh my gosh.
It looks like a real ghost is haunting me right now.
How do I get rid of it?
How?
How do I change my face back to normal?
How do I change it back to normal?
I don't know.
I think I give up.
But anyway.
Isn't it so cute?
Isn't it so, so cute?
We're cowgirls!
They're so cute.
And look!
You guys are a cactus!
So cute.
So, so, so cute.
I think this is the first time...
Ayami-sensei has drawn me as like a merch.
So, if I see you tomorrow at Anime Fest, I'll see you tomorrow!
If not, then I'll see you at whatever event or I'll see you when I stream.
I'm gonna get rid of this background.
Goodbye, background.
Goodbye.
Uh...
Yeah.
It's kinda surreal seeing Mint 1.0...
in this café.
ooooooooooooo
That's so creepy.
Okay.
Boston?
Boston.
B-B-Boston.
Bustin'.
B-b-b-b-b-bustin'!
B-b-b-bustin', bustin'!
Bustin'.
Oh my god, loud.
If there's something strange...
sleeping in your bed.
How do I get rid of this face?
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird...
sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Bustin' makes me feel...
Oh!
Yeah!
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
Hold on.
Yeah!
If you're seeing things...
sleeping in your bed.
Yeah!
An invisible man...
sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Yeah!
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
makes me feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, I'll make a prettier graphic for...
once the stuff is, you know.
Make a prettier graphic...
eventually, you know.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man, baby!
Ow!
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
Hahaha.
Uninvisible bamb.
Freaky ghost bamb.
I'm eating.
Fume.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Feel good, feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Why am I eating fried rice?
Hahaha.
Meme, meme, meme.
Mogu, mogu, mogu, mogu.
Feel
good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
KFP Ghostbusters.
Bustin', bustin', bustin' makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Bustin' makes me yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys!
Thank you guys for one year, four years!
Thank you!
I'll keep doing my best.
I'll keep doing my best!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
I'm gonna read the kudo board now.
I'm gonna read...
So thank you guys.
Thanks for whoever wrote in it.
Thank you!
Bye bye!